foreign
[Music]
thank you
net migration is at a record high the
conservatives have failed on their
election promise to bring it down and
not for the first time so should labor
be given a chance instead I'll take a
forensic look at their policy ideas and
hear from one of brexit's biggest
cheerleaders about whether the UK has
lost control of its borders this is Beth
Rigby interviews
thank you
foreign
S no buts net migration will come down
it sounds like a conservative pledge
from yesterday but in fact it's from way
back in 2011 ever since the issue of
immigration has proved a difficult nut
to crack with promises broken time and
again now net migration has hit 606
000 the highest number on record
what would labor do differently I'll be
speaking to the shadow Home Secretary
Yvette Cooper plus the former brexit
party leader Nigel farage a politician
who arguably did more than anyone else
to talk up the benefits of leaving the
EU did he over promise and has the
government under delivered
new record net migration figures have
provoked anger among some conservatives
because of the failure to deliver on a
key Manifesto pledge from the 2019
election there's also frustration from
those outside the party who campaign for
Britain to leave the EU among them Nigel
farage former leader of the brexit party
ukip and now a presenter on GB news he's
conceded that brexit has failed so where
did it all go wrong and did he and other
politicians over promise on the benefits
Nigel farage thank you so much for
coming on the show today now you are the
most famous advocate of brexit perhaps
vying with Boris Johnson and you
recently made a stark admission that
brexit had failed do you want to
apologize to voters for telling them
that we should leave the EU if it was a
failure well let's finish the sentence
brexit has failed under the Tories
yes I mean look in constitutional terms
brexit is a success we've left the
European Union we've reversed the status
quo and the reason we won the referendum
the reason the turnout was 10 higher
than all the analysts thought it was
going to be was this idea that the
population explosion in Britain caused
by immigration was diminishing people's
quality of life and and frankly that is
completely down to this government
setting the level at which people can
come for work permits basically at the
level of minimum wage
regulation immigration do you take any
responsibility
for some of the failures of brexit or
some of the promises that were made in
the campaign that were not realized any
responsibility absolutely none no
absolutely none I was very very clear
very very clear this was about reducing
numbers it was about moving to an
Australian style point system where you
set the barriers and you set the levels
so that you get genuinely skilled
migration and willfully Boris Johnson
willfully lowered those salary levels
and we've also seen this explosion of
foreign students coming to Britain being
allowed to bring dependents but the
thing is when people think of brexit
they do think of you and Boris Johnson
because you made lots of promises as
well in that campaign not really no no I
I was the one making the least number of
promises you said in June 2016 that um
you could get net migration to under 50
000. of course but I wasn't in charge
look you know had we been a European
country with proportional representation
you know I would have been in a position
of authority
to work with government to try and
achieve this as it is the irony was
here's the irony the day after the
referendum the very very people I'd
fought against for 25 years were still
in power and so what you've got and even
in 2019 you've got a government that was
given an 80 seat majority but here's the
key they never really believed in it
okay well look you also made the
promises to the British people about
controlling borders laws having trade
deals that U.S trade deal is nowhere to
be seen none of it happened though I
wonder why that is I wonder why that is
I wonder why that is but
does this make
my question actually was does this make
the public more cynical about
politicians like you that promise these
things that don't I don't do you reflect
on that I can promise you if you look at
the polling this week done by yougov
I've got it here brexiteers that are
disappointed I'm one of them you know
I'm in that number 37 of brexit Voters
are disappointed
of that 37 75 lay it firmly and squarely
at the door of this government
let me put it another way then do you
think the public might think twice about
believing what you say next time no no
but they might think twice about what
the conservatives say next time
and I think you know I think a lot of
this
is down to a breach of trust
between what has been promised to voters
at elections and what's being done and
what would be your solution in the short
term would you close off the borders and
have worker shortages in the UK to in
order to drive net migration if that
meant if that meant there was a
realistic chance of people finding
somewhere to live
a school for their kids to go to that
was local people getting access to the
National Health Service then yes of
course so you would you would shut the
borders I didn't say well you would you
use the number of workers even if that
meant shortages okay you cannot go on
look before 2004 when this really kicked
off right
cabbages were not rotting in the fields
of Lincolnshire elderly people were not
being left alone in old people's homes
we managed to do all of this and we've
now become addicted to cheap unskilled
foreign imported labor we have to
reverse that process well let's talk
about
the execution because it seems to me
that a lot of people see you as the
biggest cheerleader of brexit it hasn't
worked out in the way no that perhaps
was promised to the British people it
hasn't worked out the way it hasn't
worked out in the way that I spent
nearly 30 years campus training for but
but you won't take responsibility for
that but I wasn't getting the power I
wasn't given the power so that it's not
on me golf right I wasn't in a position
so let's talk about the execution
because let's try to get to the truth of
this I think it's fascinating about how
it could have gone better right because
you think don't you that there was
another way that brexit could have
worked for Britain and it seems to me
that your model would have been decisive
political decision for the country to
diverge from the EU slash taxes reduce
regulation build a Singapore on Thames
that that's what you wanted I never said
I know I never quoted the Singapore on
tennis but does anyone I do think I
think so much of what we do as a
government and what the European Union
does as well
is to meet the demands and needs of the
lobby groups for giant companies
there's a sector of our economy that has
been left out of this debate completely
self-employed small Traders those
businesses they were the ones that voted
brexit they were the ones that wanted an
easing a lifting of the burdens and
actually it's from those millions of
people that you get genuine economic
growth that's
at the moment it seems that we're in the
whilst of all worlds because we haven't
taken the brexit opportunities perhaps
that that you visit but but that did
involve massive Divergence deregulation
slashing taxes trying to make the UK
economically competitive I don't know we
didn't need to slash taxes remember
actually one of the few things that
George Osborne got right is we did bring
corporation tax down to a reasonable and
competitive level we've now gone we
we've now converged with France
with our corporation tax rates and you
know one of the worst things of all
that's happened and this is not being
spoken so you did want to cut
Corporation taxes I want to leave it
where it was we had a competitive
corporation tax rate well we don't with
Ireland we'd all no Ireland even more
competitive and good for them all right
but but the the short-term Necessities
were not slashing taxes post brexit the
short-term Necessities were number one
decisive political action triggering
article 50 the day after the referendum
had that been done the trade deal with
America would have been concluded but
because the conservative party yes of
course there were some that campaigned
for brexit but the party itself hated
the brexit result we've had years of
hesitancy and even when they seem to
finally get the message they didn't get
it they've never ever as a party have
believed in this but this so what the PO
it seems to me that your vision of a
pace brexit Britain was almost the
vision that Liz truss had a completely
uh for driving the economy deregulating
cut in taxes trying to compete with the
EU trade helping the little people that
was my agenda helping the little people
I always fought for that I always stood
for that and it has not happened I guess
what I'm asking you what I'm trying to
get to is whether the project was sold
to the British people
in a way that wasn't going to come to
fruition and the actual real project was
what I'm talking about the only way it
would have worked well well I look I do
think and you don't really talk to the
British people about how it was going to
work I talked to the British people
about achieving Independence all right
and and there were two areas I repeat
this there were two areas that I thought
were easily deliverable the first was
reducing this massive population
increase into our country and the second
was to lift some of the burdens off the
backs of ordinary men and women going
out there trying to earn a living they
were the two two and you know something
they were realistic expectations of
those that voted brexit and they haven't
happened and
I mean frankly frankly I look at that I
look at that 2019 story Manifesto the
way it was put to the people and frankly
it was a big lie isn't partly the truth
of net migration that for economic
growth you need a level of net migration
oh listen I've been hearing this for a
quarter of a century all right you know
you know if increasing the British
population by 8 million people has added
you know a few Pips here and there a few
decimal points here and there to GDP so
blooming what there is something that is
far more important than the size of our
GDP there is something actually called
Community there is something called
quality of life in this country and
these are things these are things that
virtually nobody in Westminster even
talks about but they are very keenly
felt outside the M25 but you made it
sound so simple in that referendum
campaign and it wasn't simple was it it
was never going to be simple what are
you doing like it was going to be a
simple thing to do well what you do it
was never going to be simple on the
morning of the 24th of June 2016 you
trigger article 50 you begin the process
no one's saying it was going to be
simple but we made it very very
difficult because we had a government
full of remainers who didn't believe in
it and I am I mean to be honest with you
there's nobody more disappointed than me
in what this government's done I'm
furious I would have loved to have been
in a position of responsibility but I
wasn't
but you promise things as well in that
referendum
that you could never deliver I think
you'll find Boris Johnson and others
were the ones making you you said you
could get I I was looking to ask for
Jude before the vote June 2016 you said
we can get net migration down to 50 000.
yes of course now whether you want to
claim Boris Johnson of course we'll look
at that and say this I believe this guy
yes I believe this guy yes I voted for
it because of this guy we could have got
it down and this guy let me down this
guy didn't come to the trees I wasn't if
you put if they put me in charge of it
would have got to 30 000 a year no
question about it but they didn't
and so the problem we've got now is I I
you know I said brexit I said 10 years
ago I wanted to cause an earthquake in
British politics all right well we got
the earthquake we're still suffering the
aftershocks so now we're all living with
the fractures well we're suffering the
aftershocks because
yes because Parliament and the
government have ignored the will of the
people they've ignored what was said in
that brexit referendum and so now
a bigger question emerges as to how
we're going to change politics in this
country ever look at it though and think
uh I I promise things to the British
people that I as a politician didn't
know if I could deliver I feel some
responsibility no because they're going
wrong no because they were never your
fault they were all no they were all
deliverable that's the point it wasn't
difficult to do that's the point maybe
they weren't as deliverable as you made
out as them to be for example with net
migration and it's awesome to Simply do
you think if I'd been in charge would
have allowed foreign students to bring
dependents in do you think if I was in
charge we'd have set you know a level
when minimum wage levels break down the
migration Figures it's not just foreign
students it's also worker visas for
shortages in the economy it's Ukrainian
Refuge level but there's a number of
components in those net migration
figures some of which you need to pick
yes at the level of minimum wage that
was not the promise that was not the
deal
so we are where we are
and when it comes to you and and the
Reform Party of which you're the
president yeah
um they did terribly in the local
elections so what does that tell you
about your repeal ability now with the
public nearly four or five percent of
seats so it's very difficult to judge
whether they did well badly to be honest
um and you know building up a national
party political structure is not an easy
thing to do but
I think the gap between Westminster and
where people are is even bigger than it
was 10 years ago
I think there will be another Insurgency
in British politics whether it'll so
whether it'll be reform whether it'll be
me
whether we get a new Nick Griffin I
trust you you made all these promises
and I don't I don't think do you not
think that you might be a busted flush
on that as I said to you if you take the
Hugo polling this week of the 37 that
are disappointed by brexit 75 percent of
them fairly and squarely at the doors of
the conservative party they're certainly
not laying it at my door and and if it's
not me and not reform then maybe we get
a Nick Griffin type figure maybe we get
genuinely the far right into British
politics something is going to change
this Gap is too big
do you genuinely think that you could
come back now and run a campaign as the
guy that's going to deliver a true
brexit given what's passed oh I think if
I stood again it would be a much more
revolutionary agenda than just brexit it
would be fundamental change to the
voting system do something people might
be watching this people that listen to
you and what you promised in 2016 about
how the country would change after
brexit and what has come to pass and
think I don't trust a thing that starts
no I think I think they'll share my
disappointment okay final question will
I see you back in Frontline politics
then in the next five years I don't know
I genuinely don't know I haven't ruled
it out I haven't ruled him in if I could
see
by doing it there was a really clear
achievable goal that I might well I
haven't worked that out yet
if we had
if we had a form
an electoral system that was
representative in some way well the
answer then it would be much easier you
you you brought
brexit to Britain and where you were the
chief cheerleader now brexit's in crisis
and your message to the British public
is it wasn't my fault
absolutely we've been let down very
badly by an entirely dishonest
establishment globalist and now remain
notorious some voters might look at and
think you were dishonest when you were
promising stuff that you could never
deliver you know what
I might have got things right I might
have got things wrong over my years in
politics I would like to think hand on
heart I was never dishonest okay Nigel
farage thank you so much I should say we
did ask the Home Secretary to come on
and speak to us about the government's
plan to tackle net migration the
invitation was declined the politician
hoping to replace her from the home
office is Labor's event Cooper so what's
her plan
that's kind of on the show today
um net migration figures have come out
today they would have shocked people I
want to come to Labor's Solutions such
as they are in a bit but first I want to
ask you about fundamental points about
your attitude to immigration how it's
evolved you supported remain in the
referendum for clarity you were in favor
of unlimited EU migration into the UK
under freedom of movement that was your
position in the past
so as you know labor did way back at the
referendums so Port remained but brexit
is in place now and we are clear we need
to make brexit work on immigration our
policy is to have a points-based system
and to reform that points-based system
not to go back to free movement actually
we need to focus on the points-based
system and how we make it work for the
UK it's not working at the moment
particularly because it is not linked to
skill shortages in the economy and some
of the long-term problems in our country
and I want to get on to Labor's policy
but the reason I asked you about that to
start off with is that labor leader
kirstarma four years after the brexit
vote stood before Labor party members
and said under the head in my pledges to
you this on migration he said defend
migrants rights full voting rights for
EU Nationals defend free movement as we
leave the EU how much of that set of
policies are still operational so we've
left the EU and Kia has said very many
times our policy as a point space system
we're not returning to free movement so
there are changes we're not returning to
free movement definitely not there are
changes we want to make to the
points-based system particularly linked
to skills yeah but the we're very clear
it's a points-based system is the right
advantage and does he want to see EU
Nationals voting in UK general elections
that's not policy I know there are
debates about all all sorts of these
issues but it's not policy he said it
back in uh 2020 he said it full voting
rights for EU Nationals and he's also
said since this is not our policy okay
so that isn't labor policy anymore
that's right it seems that low policy
have gone undergone a collective
conversion about this from freedom of
movement to now a points-based system it
has evolved clearly and I want to come
to those Solutions you talk about but
just to start off is 606
000 net migration figure is it too high
why I think the net migration should
come down from these unusually high
levels I think that we would expect it
to come down because obviously it
includes the Ukraine and Hong Kong
figures which I think everybody would
agree we support the action to help
people from Ukraine and Hong Kong but
the other concern for us in these
figures is there's been a doubling of
the number of work visas in just a few
years they've gone up by a hundred and
twenty percent and we still have skills
shortages across the country so that I
think is the real failing and that's why
our policies would actually address some
of these skills you don't have this
continual switch towards overseas
recruitment rather than training
migration good or bad for the UK economy
we're always going to need International
Recruitment and let's be clear that our
country has benefited for Generations
from people who've come here to build
our biggest businesses to work in our
public services and be part of our
country that's who we are but this
system also needs to be properly
controlled and managed so that it's fair
and there is this problem at the heart
of it which is these growing skills
shortages that are never never being
addressed and that's why we want those
skill shortages addressed of course in
something like Health and Social care
we're going to continue to need a health
and social care Visa but it's a serious
problem that we're just not training
enough nurses and doctors here in the UK
your big sort of policy is around skill
shortages you're not going to give an
overall Target for migration figures but
will you promise the British people that
there will be fewer work visas granted
by labor than the current government
there were three hundred thousand in the
year to March 2023 so can I take it that
given this is the centerpiece of your
policy you will at least pledge that to
the British people that you will bring
the number of work visas down over a
labor government well we're not set in
targets but what we are doing is setting
practical policies I think that's the
right way to do it because to be honest
I think for too long people have seen
ever since 2010 people have seen
politicians sit there and set targets
and make all these promises and they've
all actually been meaningless so what
we're instead doing is setting out what
the policies would be and the policies
would be to say when you've got
occupations on the shortage occupation
list which accounts for around half of
all skilled worker visas those jobs
should be linked to proper training
plans in the UK Engineers have been on
the shortage list for about 15 years no
proper plan to make sure you get the
training in the UK so you've got 50 000
shortfall every year According to some
estimates so you link it first of all
with the training plans particularly
that means around the NHS where we would
have a substantial increase which would
mean the NHS wouldn't need the same
scale of recruitment from overseas and
then also I don't know if you want to
come on to this getting rid of this pay
discount in the immigration system which
is also really unfair and is an
incentive for employers to recruit from
overseas rather than to remember to
train in the UK you've made it clear
that you want to tackle skill shortages
with domestic workers but what I'm
hearing too is that labor are having a
go at the government about net migration
figures and at the same time you won't
set your own targets about where you
want the level to go to neither will you
commit to Bringing Down the level of
work visas now so I think that's having
your cake and eat it you have a go at
them but you won't set your own targets
that is what is clear to me well what
we're criticizing them for is having no
plan and having no grip and that
ultimately is the difference both on
immigration and us on Asylum we're
setting everything
if you say we will have this plan but
you won't give them anything to measure
you about which is for example not
unreasonable if you're going to train
all these workers to say by the end of
the next Labor Parliament elects Naval
government over five years we will bring
work visas down from the current levels
that seems to me a very modest ambition
if you deliver on these pledges
I think the more important thing to be
honest is to set out the Practical plan
and I can go through another part of our
plan which would be a substantial reform
we would get rid of the current 20
discount in the immigration system which
means that employers where they've got
shortage occupation which is a lot of
occupations they can recruit people at
20 percent less than the going rate the
going rate's already lower than the
average rate so that is a really big
discount on average pay that allows
employers to recruit at level that level
from overseas now that is an incentive
for those employers to recruit from
overseas rather than to train at home
rather than to pay fairly at home and to
be honest I just think everybody I
should be paid the going rate Kirsten
has talked about when he sees a vision
for Britain he hasn't talked about A
Five-Year Plan he has talked about a
decade plan he has talked if you like in
blue thinking terms or Blue Sky Thinking
about a 10-year program for government I
mean annalize Dodds your predecessor and
Labor's chair has been honest about
about it she told Sky News potential in
some areas where there's a short-term
need for skills you could see in the
short term actually people who are
coming in increasing in numbers that
that's true isn't it it could actually
go up before it comes down fair I think
that um the net migration figures I
believe in that migration figures should
come down and also actually I would
expect them to come down because you've
got Ukraine figures and uh the other
figures around Hong Kong as well but we
also think on the issues around the work
visas we really should be investing in
the UK and we really should be investing
in training as well don't get me wrong
there will always be important
International Recruitment and that will
continue to be the case we're going to
need talent and skills you know the best
talent and skills from all over the
world and my right into thinking that
you did not like the storm attack ads
claiming the Prime Minister does not
believe adults convicted of sexually
assaulting children are going to go to
prison
like that did you I'm not going to
apologize for hard-hitting ads that
recognize that the Prime Minister has
been in charge and is part of a
conservative country a conservative
government that has been in charge for
13 years there have been a whole series
of failures around the criminal justice
system and one of the biggest failures
has been the huge drop in the charge
rate that's across all kinds of crimes
you know we've dropped from about
two-thirds in terms of the charge rate
that does bluntly mean more criminals
are getting off and more victims are
being let down the reason I asked partly
vote if you don't mind is that the
Fallout of that rare was taught that
you'd slightly fallen out with starmer
that he might not you might not
continuous had Shadow Home Secretary is
that all rubbish
do you expect to have this that job
going into the generalization take the
rubbish and that here and I work really
closely together including on all of
these issues all of the time but you
know you and I Beth have been around for
quite a long time and we sadly we don't
we never take too seriously the sort of
you know nonsense gossip and stuff that
you know will always appear in the
papers and let's be clear in the run-up
to a general election we know there will
be all kinds of stuff appearing in the
papers that's total nonsense and that'll
be attacking us we're really going into
the general about the important thing is
that we're working together as a team
and actually setting out policies that
we have worked on together as a team
that that Kier and I have worked on that
I've been working on let's kill this
with Rachel with Bridget and so on so
let's kill this off now to be clear you
will be the shadow Home Secretary going
into the driver well look I'm keeping
working on this it's you know it's it's
for kids set out the team that he wants
and that's for him just final question
because the Sky News investigation has
revealed abuses of the skilled worker
visa scheme which allowed migrants to
come here to work and bring dependents
Sky uncovered the abuse of the scheme by
people traffickers who charge huge
amounts of money to get visas then send
them fake dependents to accompany the
workers who then disappear into the UK
and arrival how worried are you about
those sorts of allegations
so I think it is really serious the way
some of the criminal gangs operate
particularly the trafficking gangs there
are also people smugger operations and
so on and we think much stronger action
is needed to go after the criminal gangs
it's partly why we've said we need a new
cross-border unit policing unit to go
after the criminal gangs but that's to
go after them in the UK and uh across
and in across Europe as well and to work
with other forces to do so I am very
worried that some of the government's
legislation is actually watering down
the action against these trafficking
gangs we think that enforcement needs to
be much stronger rather than weaker okay
in fact Cooper thank you so much for
your time appreciate it thank you thank
you well I hope you enjoyed this week's
conversations with the vet Cooper and
Nigel farage on a theme that affects all
of our Lives if you scan the QR code on
the left of your screen you'll be able
to watch all of our previous episodes
online and if you scan the QR code on
your screen right now you can listen to
the Beth Rigby interviews podcast each
week I take a look at the highlights of
my interviews and reflect on the
political week too that'll be on the Sky
News app or wherever you get your
podcasts
well that's all for today's show thank
you so much for watching
[Music]
um